In a city of darkness...
...where evil runs free,...
...the people need a hero.
Who am I?
I'm Dragonfly.
Stop!
The story of my life is not for the faint of heart.
Stop the bus!
Seven genetically enhanced super dragonflies.
But there's only six in there.
From the makers of "Scary Movie" and "The Naked Gun"...
There we go.
Uncle Albert!
Rick!
How did you do that?
It's easier than it looks.
Well, I don't think so.
...comes the ultimate superhero movie.
I think I have super powers.
I can walk on walls. I have super strength, super agility.
Honor.
Take cover!
Uncle Albert!
With great power comes great...
Just try to breathe.
I can't. You're kneeling on my crotch.
Family.
Hi, everybody. Take your seat.
Uh-uh-uh! Not 'til we say grace.
Amen!
Sacrifice.
I realize we can never be together.
You love me Rick.
I know you do.
I'm telling you this for your own good.
This spring,...
...if you think you've seen it all,...
...you have no idea.
You just saved that old lady's life.
If I hadn't pushed her out of the way, she would have died.
Superhero Movie.